[Music]
three
two one action this is so risky
wow this is so risky how do you do that
ying yang honey balance
i can't do that yin yay honey balance
is that a new junebe flavor yin yang
honeybee honey bottle
i like it i'm pitching it oh snaps i
[ __ ] up and didn't get a june b
i'm on time i'm waiting for someone to
[ __ ] drop it my shit's too cool
honey balance
that's my uh my my only fans account
oh honey balance actually that is a hell
of a like an asian stripper name
ying yang honeybot the pole requires a
lot of balance
yeah and yin yang is asian and the honey
just because the pussy's sweet
next on stage we got the sweet
yellow wall yin yang honey balance
beautiful splits totally missed what she
was doing holy [ __ ] i know it's okay
look away look at that oh no
are you wearing a mask what would you
what would your stripper theme song be
oh i'm a boss ass [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that one is still um the song like if
when i'm doing stand-up when they ask me
what song i want to come up to that's
the one that's the one you guys come up
to
songs if they allow it if they ask me
not usually but it's got to be like
clearable though right yeah well no no
no no this is i mean
it's not like it's on netflix this is
just like you know at a random bar in
wheels
like they can play whatever song they
want but there's always a song when you
bring people up but sometimes
they'll ask what song do you want my
neck my back um no you know what's
actually popping as [ __ ] my my roommate
uh vanessa michaels the one that
produces she actually made
a remix of boss ass [ __ ] but um the
vocals on top of that
dude you weren't offended
it was it was really it's really good no
it wasn't it was a request i made i was
like can you make this
if you didn't request it would you be
offended no
that's actually pretty funny like i just
wake up one day and she's like
playing this like why'd you choose that
the oriental tunes
if you will if you will all the black
keys
oh black keys see i know nothing about
piano okay i get it i get it now
you're like the only asian that doesn't
also i know i took that
[Music]
back if you
hands down everyone knows how to play
chinese music
why if you just go up and down here and
play the black keys on the piano
you got it i've never is that also a
hookah
every key is a different flavor
anthony
[Laughter]
i'm [ __ ] mind blown right now i can't
believe he actually just proved that now
he's sitting next to him
no this is already i discovered this
when i was a child on the t
on the on the yeah stupid he knew since
he was a kid
but i felt like everyone with the piano
knew this when they were a kid they're
just if you
could afford a got you piano
yeah i'm pretty rich we were on welfare
and we had one
oh you must get really poor
[Laughter]
what's even below welfare uh i don't
know
wayfair oh right exactly way fair
dark real quick yeah yeah wait look wait
yeah wayfarer really went through it
yeah
wait where was that mall yeah yeah yeah
yeah we're on the same page yes um
absolutely we weren't on welfare i i was
um
i was uh no i did take lessons when i
was a kid like piano lessons and like my
parents were really strict about it that
sounds about right
but then my and i was good too i could
like read music and do my thing i forgot
you know a little bit of a little little
air tickle mm-hmm
if you will if you will um but my
[ __ ] teacher like fled to taiwan one
day
that's a specific word i teach this
[ __ ] anymore
she stole down and walked
yeah she like slammed the bucket of the
thing on my finger i know
i got you now you're like ah and she
left no she just bounced and then i just
like didn't continue without her
oh damn and then but might find her on
facebook i don't even know her name oh
isn't that kind of what happened with
your ballet lessons yeah i was just
thinking about it
wait your teacher just said peace well
she died
oh no smith and fled
are like a teacher is no longer teaching
her so she stopped so she hated geo so
much
she created what if my my piano teacher
actually did die
and my parents just were trying to hide
the hurt
we're the same because we i couldn't
move on i'm too loyal
what if my piano teacher and your ballet
dancer
teacher was the same person and they
just like they were con
artists oh my collective parents money
she was yours
mine was asian no she was pretty white
with blue eyes but also shape shifters
wow i knew that was coming
or it's just a collective of cons
right scammers so they're one company
one company yes
that teaches children but they don't
actually teach them and they run away
yes exactly they get the money they do
like oh yeah yeah yeah this one like
this like that like that recital
i did that no no no wait wait no i never
even got to the recital i was weirdo
how many lessons did you have then it's
kind of blurry this was seventh grade
no but also in china we had this wooden
piano
wait what you're from china okay
so you grew up in china no well i went
back a lot i spent a lot of summers
there when i was little but i was born
there and i came to
america when i was four are you a
citizen yes
you went through this last time papers
i have a pdf i have a pdf of my papers
prove it
no no no i'm just curious because i was
like wait you grew up half of your life
in china
and then i'm like i just set up until
four yeah i was four well
so she's eight i'm currently eight years
old
i actually turn nine next week yeah uh
scorpio
you know what part of the story i forgot
to tell you that i wrote in
is that what the [ __ ] her your story
that i wrote in for you you come back
and forth right and i'm assuming that
you would do one semester of school
there one semester of school here
because you're a spy right because i'm
the real shape shifter
the whole time so you slam the piano on
your own fingers
shift the entire time crazy my taiwanese
piano teacher never even existed she was
part of my imagination i was
did you co-write with christopher nolan
or something
yeah janet we are the i was heading i'm
with you i'm with you i i don't know
what the [ __ ] going on
first of all i feel like i'm watching
tanner right now spiked by lacroix
you brought it in girl i don't know [ __ ]
lagroy
yeah shut up i've been honestly shouting
them out for
[ __ ] years and no sponsorship no
hashtag
is always there for you you know in
times of need lonely nights
a little junebe a big spoon little spoon
and i come with the package sometimes
if i'm not traveling are you a big spoon
or a little spoon joe
both mmm which one do you prefer yeah
he's just curled up in a circle by
himself
i like to be big spoon oh because of the
morning wood
you smart honey i know it at night
i'm probably little spoon because i
busted i'm trying to go to sleep and
then i'm getting bothered
she's like knock knock she's like can i
cut them like okay i just fine okay
interesting i feel like i get like hot
so easily i do too
i'm not that big of a cuddle yeah we
sweat a lot and we it's your legs
we managed for 20 seconds through the
sweat we're like yeah this is
comfortable yeah we like it we like it
oh [ __ ] don't tell anyone i'm married
have you tried this case you got sweaty
[ __ ] legs i just
i'm too hot i'm too hot i get pretty
[ __ ] hot
behind the knees absolutely bruh the
hottest part it's a bowl of soup oh yeah
absolutely
he tried this case where you just sleep
naked with no covers
and then tiff is actually in the covers
but her arms are around you
so then her arm is your blanket i hate
being big spoon
okay okay i don't know what the hell
that was some like uh origami vibes
there
i tried that was like a game of twister
wait i was doing pretzels now i was like
what's like a spring roll
yeah those are spring rolls this one
here yeah it's just tiff covered him on
top of the cover and she goes look
yeah but not not like spooning him
though
i don't like being a big spoon i think
we wake up that way
okay when i wake up i'm like oh yeah
she's guys like one arm over
hot too i have to have the ac on at
night and oh i can't do ac at night
because
i'm cold the asian superstition of like
your ass will get sick
that [ __ ] didn't exist in japanese
superstars no we're
no piano no ac your childhood sucks hey
you know what
i appreciate little things now
is it is it the fan you can't have the
fan blowing when you're sleeping
something all right well sometimes it's
fine because you don't have ac so that's
like just fun well sometimes i hire an
actual fan to come over
and you
the way it goes is the wind will catch
you six feet away but the corona will
fall within three
so it's like sometimes like yeah because
nowadays
yeah wow that was nice oh [ __ ] nowadays
corona is the big spoon dangerous video
a dangerous video this is extreme sports
now
this is where we've evolved honey we are
going baby we are going
uh damn i had another [ __ ] you know
what else is pretty good
if you can't get [ __ ] at home
today's video is brought to you by adam
and eve during these times
of pandemia it is the best to practice
abstinence so you married couples need
to be abstinent
abstinent because you don't want corona
no karma and nobody wants corona right
so
so the best way to kind of deal with
this is sex toys
right what if you want to use it with
your partner but we can't because we
have to be absent
you have to get the centaur you have to
have the vibration uh
up down top bottom side to side okay
baby
i'm left sometime right sometimes blue
sometimes red but today blue
but best of all free stuff is awesome
but free stuff to spice up your bedroom
is even better
so i guess if you are married you're
allowed to [ __ ]
thank you thank you yes i need to do
permission
thank you i recommend using a vibrator
well this is not written here but this
is my personal
experience use a vibrator or a string
cheese
clitoris and uh the uh casey can
insert you oh okay select me select
almost
any one item for 50 off and then adam
and eve
loads on the free stuff okay so enter
offer code otr at checkout and get 10
tantalizing free gifts a sexy item for
him
a special gift for her and a third item
you'll both enjoy
and six free spicy movies oh plus
free shipping that's otr offer
code otr at checkout
adamandeve.com um
i see movies what's the spiciest movie
you've ever seen
the spicy
the italian one that everyone [ __ ]
all the chicks were just talking about
you mean
when the girls are doing lesbian stuff
it's an italian guy who falls in love
with like this swiss
chick and he like holds her captive and
so the meme was it's not even me but
it's like it was
oh i've seen it's on netflix yeah he
like grabs her by the [ __ ] neck
oh that's that's the literally the
thumbnail yeah
i don't know i don't watch it have you
heard of 365 i was recommended that
that's the one
wait oh my god that's what it is that's
the one okay
it's like the it's like now's uh uh of
that book that came out that
great shape these are crucial is it
english
yes or subtitles well i was i only
watched sometimes
just turn on the english side i was
recommended to watch this movie
perform it on the person that
recommended it it's pretty cheesy but it
could be hot
it's not my style i think oh you watched
it no i i haven't yet
wait i saw the trailer um
what kind of style was it very like too
romantic
no it's very dominant like like oh you
like being more sub
what is it about oh he just ignored me
okay so it's this mafia guy
uh his family gets shot up burned some
[ __ ] so he has to take on like the whole
moth like he's mocking
that's the part i don't like uh no but
that sounds like something you would
like
so then he sees this chick right and
like he's he caught a glimpse of her he
like it was like love at first or lust
at first sight forgets about her
um and then he runs into her again
kidnaps her and he goes
hey i'm gonna make you fall in love with
me and then
that's the that's the basic premise i
did that and then is she into it
uh do you want spoilers are we going to
watch it i think we're going to watch it
together
right well she resists a lot and then
she's like but it's just
beauty and the beast
very good but the guy's very yeah oh
beauty and the beast is like
i mean erotic number one erotic number
one i'm with you they shouldn't make
your beauty and beast
girl baby girl that clock can get it
this message that body
that body that [ __ ] pole mrs potts
misses my back when i say misty cup yeah
that was before that was her own name
remember the dresser you married mrs
potts leave the dresser out of it too
be my guest be my brother better than
belle
she was a [ __ ] belle the other one the
other girl not belle
what other girl one of the girls oh [ __ ]
that was a portal
the three girls the three blonde chicks
that were like hot for gaston
no i was thinking about a live action
porno oh all right a booty in the
beast beauty and the yeast
oh no booty in the breast oh i got weird
that got weird that was that's the spicy
movie
it's booty in the breast spicy movies
oh just because no they said spicy movie
in the little uh
vibrator vibrator promo shari's kind of
horny so that's why she always wants to
ask questions like that i am in
heat honey this is about to go straight
to my nostrils
from which oh i believe this is the
asian reboot of jackass right now you
know what i realized
is um i do not like violence in the
bedroom
it scares me i do like a little slapping
a little smacking
done to you or due to them that kind of
slapped like that
loud sorry no i'm a really loud clapper
like
okay is that to the butt or to the face
though insane oh hold on my best
no um i like doing it well you like
slapping
revisit the fact i'm bisexual i went to
revisit just
i don't know people were confused no
anyway wait why would that be confusing
because you don't know i have to specify
i'm slapping a boy but
ah or a girl butt or my own butt no but
do
sometimes i just like i'm in my room
slapping my own butt
45 minutes and i get off 45 minutes
that's it you are an asian grandma dude
10 minutes
each cheek each cheek because balance
cause honey
you need honey balance listen i'm all
about the symmetry
let me ask you ying yang when you slap
though you just mentioned butt right
you don't [ __ ] whack him in the face
i know i've never
a slap face watch till you experience
that and see if you like
violence in the bedroom you got slides
in the face [ __ ] yeah i got slapped in
the face
man i think for joe we shouldn't talk
about it do you ever slap like
any other is it just face or butt or is
it also like cast like you know those
old asian people that just slapped the
face
at the park i don't know what they're
doing with that it's for the blood
circulation
that's what we're doing in the bathroom
is getting the blood circulating that
makes sense
i need my [ __ ] cheek to wake up slap
penis on
cheek i'll i don't that happens i hate
that like a boner flick
yeah a little something yeah that's not
really violent
i don't hate that what about the kicks
in the chest oh yeah
300 kicks in the stomach i couldn't even
finish but
don't look at me next time what about
like biting off the nipple and then
sewing it back
on and then binding it off again
and then putting it on a bulletin board
what about the fist thing in the mouth
it's this joe everyone knows it's this
in the mouth there's a little bell in
the back no
this is i can't i can't do this thing
why do they call it this i can't do it
in my
mouth
so what about the pornos where they do
this unless it's like this
is it's a sandwich
it's a it's a weird deformed fist
wait well try it okay everyone do the
weird deformed fist
as if you're holding a knife oh like
you're like your steak knife oh yeah
this is literally what you do when you
hold it right
this with the whole fist
versus this i'm so dry the fact that you
have technique right now is impressive
and then this
yes that works too but it's not the fist
and it's back i think this is the bird
beak right
it's like this right here it's easier to
enter yeah
that's true i got two noses
two noses damn dude i'm so glad i don't
got those kind of things
what kind of a butthole oh like fisting
buttholes
right right not into it yeah i think
yeah i
i like vanilla [ __ ] right it's a lot of
work i mean it's like the rusty trombone
is pretty vanilla
pretty i think it's the next blower
that's that's pretty no no that's pretty
standard
see no that's that's you believe in me
but they're teaching that in schools now
like that's an
unhealthy you guys are too missionary i
no you know what i would do
this is the vision i have in my head for
for just i want to share with everyone
because i can't get out of my head now
the new shirt off the butthole but then
you throw it one side
oh wow that's west coast that's a lot of
strength to like
push the pinky out that left hand
because my right hand i have like the
trouble
oh [ __ ] do you do one of these yeah
yeah sometimes i wanna i wanna throw up
real fast and i'm just like
right just pretend fake it fake it fake
it fake it fake it this is like the
blade sword
you know what i mean like you go inside
yeah oh yeah oh like the sword
swallowers yeah you got it
no but yes the other way put your ring
finger over your
your middle finger oh that's [ __ ] oh
my god that's impossible oh my god no
i'm doing it but also it took me so long
to get here oh cause i'm trying to see
if i can do both ways
i wish i was born with claws what what
kind of claws like wolverine
like wolverine
[Music]
you